with the large amount of molecular
characterization data available today
precision medicine offers the best
strategy for medical treatment
it is a medical model that proposes the
customization of medical treatment of
products being tailored to a subgroup of
patients
drug therapy response protection also
assessed in customization of drug
treatment
hello everyone i am um
the work that i am going to present
today is about drug therapy response
prediction in dlpcl patients
using machine learning approach
let us first
understand
diffuse large b cell lymphoma
tlpcl
is a cancer of the lymphatic system it
constitutes 30 of all cases of
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
it is characterized by markedly
heterogeneous clinical course
and the response to the therapy is not
well appreciated with standard
histopathological
and immunophenotypic evaluations
and hence there is a need to predict the
therapeutic response of tlpcl
and develop more precise therapeutic
regimens for tlpcl
to address this issue this issue
personalized medicine approach could be
used as it relies on patients medical
history genomic characteristics
and genomic characteristics to provide
the most effective treatment strategy
based on response to therapy
accumulation
of drug sensitivity and multi-omics data
makes it possible to leverage systems
biology to identify association between
molecular features and drug and estimate
drug response to guide personalized
medicine
so the aim of this work is to develop
machine learning algorithm that would
predict the response to therapy
drug therapy utilizing gene expression
data of dlpcl patients
machine learning algorithm on gene
expression data of tlcvcs
dlpcl-specific cell models would be used
to predict the class of response to drug
therapy
methodology is explained in the work
flow chart
given below
rnac and drug data was downloaded from
genomics of drug sensitivity in cancer
website the truck data was filtered by
applying
the ic50 threshold
drugs with the lowest ic50 value was
searched on nih nci website for proper
annotation
from the top tracks five routes were
shortlisted for further analysis
further cell model annotation was done
based on the median ic50 value as
threshold for categorization
cell models with ic50 value lower than
the threshold are sensitive and those
with a higher ic50 value
median ic50 value were considered as
resistive
further the gene expression data was
subsetted corresponding to the cell
models on which the particular drug is
tested
further gene expression data was also
filtered by applying a tpm of greater
than five
and this data was used for further
analysis
so in total for the five drugs
including gliomyosin acetylene fortinet
ibrutinib and volunt we had around 20 25
17 32 and 24 samples respectively
the methodology of data analysis
is explained in the flow chart given
below
all the data analysis work was performed
on power bi informatics
server
the exploratory data analysis
included principal component analysis
it was performed for the gene expression
data corresponding to cell models on
which each of the five drugs
were tested separately the number of
pieces selected with three
supervised learning algo
algorithm were applied to the data
and before that the data was split into
train and test data sets for each of the
five tracks including blue my
does the gene expression data
corresponding to cell models on which
each of the five drugs were tested was
split into trained and tested assets
further random forest and support vector
machine algorithm were applied to the
train and test data sets the number of
decision trees
to construct from random subsets of
training data
was selected as 500
whereas
whereas the svm kernel type was set as
linear
confusion metrics
for training data and precision on and
prediction on test
set were assessed to determine the
accuracy of machine learning models
so the methodology is further
shown
as
the the pipeline that was
performed on uh
tower by informatics platform is
predicted here
the pc analysis
the random forest with 500 trees and
svm
with
linear as
the kernel type
further we will
try to understand the results of the
analysis
pca
uses an orthogonal transformation to
convert a set of observations of
possibly related
correlated variables into a set of
values of linearly uncorrelated
variables called principal components
therefore pc analysis plots
gives gene profiles on a 2d plane
generating a visual crafts where it is
easy to see the groups that are
associated
components are the underlying structure
in the data
in these plots we can see the resistive
groups and the sensitive groups
represented by red and blue dots
respectively
but we cannot see
strong grouping of the sensitive and
resistive classes
separately
for drug response studies pca plots are
not always representative of the complex
behavior of the system and that is the
case that we could not see strong
grouping or strong classification of the
two classes
let us see the results of random forest
random forest is a classification
algorithm based on decision tree
approach the algorithm generates
multiple decision trees from random
subsets of training set
we can see that the total number of
correct predictions for gliomyosin was
three out of five for perseverance the
correct predictions were five out of
seven or fourteen four out of five and
it wrote in seven out of ten correct
predictions and for warren was that
the correct predictions were five out of
seven
so from the graph we can see that the
prediction accuracy was
highest for train and test data for
ibrutinib
random forest performed better for drugs
with highest number of samples
let us now try to understand the results
of svm predictions
svm focuses on separate on separating
the points that lie near the boundary
between the classes
so the results of the cvm for biomycine
are four out of five correct predictions
vasodilate five out of seven correct
predictions three out of five correct
predictions for fortinet
and
seven out of ten correct predictions for
ibrutinib
followed by six out of seven correct
predictions for volunteering
so we can see that swim performed better
for vorinostat
let us now understand
the
comparison of ml model across drugs
as compared to random forest svm
performed better in terms of accuracy
for all drugs except for fortinet
which had very low number of samples or
cell models
so
we can conclude that svm performed
better as compared to random forest
let us now move ahead
towards the discussion of the world
robust classification of type of
response to drug used in treatment will
guide the steps in personalized medicine
in this project genetically
characterized dlpcl cell models could be
categorized as sensitive or resistive to
the treatment with drugs including
gliomycin bosotinin fortinet ibrutinib
and vorinostat this would help in
determining the response to therapy in
patients with tlbcl and thus would
be a step in the direction of precision
medicine for dlpcl
[Music]
further
i would like
to conclude this presentation with a few
important points that
drug therapy response prediction is
crucial for determination of effective
treatment for cancer patients
we conclude that machine learning model
trained on omics data can assist in
determining
in determining whether the sample is
sensitive or resistive to a particular
drug therapy thereby providing options
to personalize therapy
for patients
with this i conclude my presentation
thank you